d'abord il y a eu cette imposante
colonne de fumée menaçant tout l'horizon
au dessus du port de beyrouth puis une
puissante déflagration
une deuxième explosion a graduellement
tout soufflé sur son passage
le quartier voisin d'achraf y est à des
kilomètres plus loin dans quartier
central d'al hamra certains ont vu venir
mineduc table chercher un abri
d'autres ont carrément été pris par
surprise sous les décombres les morts
les blessés partout
des milliers d'habitants de beyrouth à
gars ont dû se rendre à pied dans les
hôpitaux qui ont vite été débordés
nous étions à la maison raconte cette
femme et nous avons entendu un bruit
comme des feux d'artifice nous pensions
qu'un conteneur avait pris feu dans le
port quelques secondes plus tard nous
avons été projetés dans les airs selon
le ministère de l'intérieur les
explosions sont probablement dues à des
matières explosives confisqué depuis des
années 2700 tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
qui sont restés là dans l'indifférence
des autorités
inacceptable a dit le président michel
aoun qui appelle à un état d'urgence
pour les deux prochaines semaines
julio montt razim les responsables de la
catastrophe seront jugés a promis le
premier ministre en direct à la
télévision libanaise la france l'iran le
royaume uni ont comme beaucoup d'autres
nations exprimer leur solidarité avec le
peuple libanais est offert de l'aide
plus étonnant peut-être israël toujours
en guerre avec le liban a aussi offert
une aide humanitaire et médicale par le
biais de canaux diplomatiques
c'est le moment de transcender les
conflits peut-on lire sur le compte
twitter de l'armée israélienne le sort
continue de s'acharner sur le pays du
cèdre et sa population
le liban connaît sa pire crise
économique depuis des décennies
dépréciation de sa monnaie inédite
hyperinflation licenciements massifs les
restrictions bancaires drastique la
grogne sociale est alimentée depuis des
mois la nuit tombée l'incendié aux ports
contrôlés beyrouth blessé dans sa chair
est sans électricité et de nouveau
plongé dans le noir quasi totale une
nuit qui semble ne plus vouloir par
classe à la lumière au jour venu ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris